- [Mark] All right T.
T where are you from originally?
Where'd you grow up?
- [T] Compton.
- [Mark] Tell me about your family.
You grew up with both of your parents?
- Yeah, went to school,
was brought up nice,
but somehow I end up bad.
(Mark chuckles)
- [Mark] Tell me about your childhood.
- Shit, I didn't have no childhood really.
I started fucking up when I was like 15
and I've been fucking up ever since,
they tried to raise me
right but somehow...
- [Mark] So your parents were good
and they were there for you,
but you just kinda went
a different direction?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] What age were you
when you left your parents' house?
- 17.
- [Mark] 17?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Where'd you go from there?
- Job Corps, I fucked up there,
went to the military.
I got an honorable discharge, then shit,
I just been fucking up, I
don't know what's wrong.
- [Mark] What eh...
You're now a pimp for some of
the girls here on Skid Row?
- Yap.
- [Mark] One of the
girls is Candace, right?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] I know Candace.
Is this something that you saw as a kid?
You saw guys doing that in
your neighborhood stuff like?
- No.
- [Mark] No?
What do you think led
you down that, to this?
- I needed some money,
shit they was out there doing it,
so I might go be they pimp, you know?
- [Mark] What's the arrangement?
The girls work for you,
they bring the money
and then you do what?
- I break 'em off,
they only one dope, but
I give them money too,
they stay with me, some of them.
- [Mark] Yeah, I went by your tent.
You got like three girls
living with you, right?
- Yeah, I was wrong.
I think I'm getting tired,
I'm trynna get out of downtown,
it's kinda rough,
I've been down here like five years.
- [Mark] Yeah, have you done prison time?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] What kinda stuff
you been in prison for?
- Shit, robbery, attempted murder,
I just got out.
I've been out five years, I got out.
I did 18 years, straight.
- [Mark] What for?
- Robbery.
- [Mark] Robbery?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Do you have kids of your own?
- Two girls.
- [Mark] Did you raise them?
- When I went to prison they
was like about seven and nine
and I ain't seen them in all them years.
When I got out I tried to talk to them,
but they act like they don't know me,
they was acting like I was
a stranger or something.
- [Mark] Right.
- So, I don't talk with them no more.
I had a place but, some girl burned it.
So, I got a place last year,
I was only in there for nine days,
she burned it, they kicked me out.
I'm trying to find another
place, but it's hard.
- [Mark] Yeah,
what are the personality traits
you need to work as a pimp?
You need to have what traits
to get a girl to work for you?
- Oh, charisma, you gotta have, finesse,
you gotta treat them right.
If they treat you right,
- [Mark] Does force
or intimidation come into
the picture sometimes?
- [T] Not with me.
- [Mark] Not with you?
- [T] Yeah, if they don't wanna
do it then I ain't gon' trip
I ain't gon' turn nobody out,
if they doing it already.
- [Mark] What are the traits
a girl needs to do this,
to work for you?
- [T] She gotta look good.
She gotta act right,
that's about it.
And don't be stealing,
get a man what he paying for,
that way won't be no problems.
- [Mark] What are your plans
down the road, for the future?
Do you have anything
you'd like to see happen?
- Four more months,
that's my goal to be outta downtown.
- [Mark] Are you using any of
the drugs that are out here?
- I use a little bit of
crystal, I got to stay up.
- [Mark] How much do the
girls bring in at night?
- 500,
- [Mark] How much?
- 500
- [Mark] Per girl?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] That's pretty good.
- I don't, keep my girls down here,
they ain't gonna make shit down here.
- [Mark] Better neighborhoods
for making money, right?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Where do you guys go, Figueroa?
- I go to Hollywood
- [Mark] Hollywood?
- Yeah
- [Mark] Like Western?
- Western, there's a lot of places.
I go to the beach
sometimes, to The Valley.
'Cause down here, it ain't nothing but...
If I was a girl,
I wouldn't do nothing down here.
- [Mark] Right? Yeah.
You make, you make a
fraction of the money, right?
- Or John end up kicking your
ass taking the money back
and don't give you nothing at all.
- [Mark] Yeah, it's crazy our here.
- Yeah.
(sniffles)
- [Mark] All right,
well T thank you so much
for talking to me.
- What'd you do?
- I'm a photographer.
I just find these stories down
here interesting. (chuckles)
Everybody's got an interesting
story to tell, like you do.
- You don't go nowhere else?
- [Mark] What do you mean?
The neighborhoods?
Oh yeah.
Yeah. I go all around.
I've been down here cause it's just like,
every time I come down here,
there's more interesting stuff.
Like you, you just walked
into my lap today, right?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] This neighborhood is charged full
of interesting people like you,
but one day and sometimes
I go to other neighborhoods
and find interesting stuff elsewhere too.
'Cause there's stuff like this going on,
all over the country,
- Yeah
- [Mark] Not just right here in Skid Row,
but Skid Row does have a ton of it.
So I don't have to work too hard,
I just show up here
(T chuckles)
and it falls into my lap,
but I've been to other places
and it's probably time to st--
- What you doing in life?
- [Mark] What am I doing tonight?
- Nope. I mean,
- [Mark] Going to Lakers game.(chuckles)
- No, what you do in life?
- [Mark] Oh in life,
What did you become?
- [Mark] I'm a photographer.
- That's what you been doing--
- [Mark] Yeah, I support
myself shooting advertising,
photography, for companies that need ads
and stuff like that,
that's how I make money, I
don't make money doing this,
I bleed money doing this,
but I find it interesting.
- So you making money and
just like giving it away?
- [Mark] I'm basically
giving it away, yeah.
- You don't really need it?
- [Mark] No, money is important,
I don't wanna give it away,
but I don't think you
would come in here for $5.
- Shit, if I was desperate I would.
- [Mark] Yeah, so I have to
end up paying people like you,
to come in here,
and sometimes that costs
me 20 bucks or more.
People like you, I probably
have to pay quite a bit more
than 20, but a lot of the heroin addicts
that are out here in the street,
that are doing the craziest stuff,
are happy to come in here for 20 bucks
and I'm happy to pay 'em for that.
I have them sign a release,
we do a little talk and
I put it on YouTube.
- And people see it?
- [Mark] Yeah.
I'm very new at it so it's like,
I started off with getting
like 12 or 15 views a day,
and now, it's growing and
it's growing pretty quickly.
So it's kind of encouraging
to see people kind of,
some people can't watch this stuff.
It's just too dark. (chuckles)
It's too disturbing, but
other people will find it,
I think you can learn a
lot about human nature,
you can learn a lot about what's
going on with our society,
you can find out about
some of the problems
that we have as a country,
by watching these things,
'cause it's a complex problem.
It's racism, it's wealth inequality,
it's opportunity and education inequality,
it's self-esteem issues,
it's self worth, it's everything.
- I think the government is causing this.
- [Mark] The government
is a huge part of it.
Because, the black
community is so beaten down,
like I talk to some of these gang kids
and they're like,
"What options did you
have as a kid?" (chuckles)
"I didn't have any", you know?
when I was a kid growing
up in suburban Chicago--
- Well, back in our day
I don't think we really had non, but now
I think the young kids, if
they wanna do something right,
they got opportunities and shit.
- [Mark] Well, I mean,
they do and they don't,
it's still really rough
for a lot of people.
In certain neighborhoods,
it's just it's so...
- Yeah.
- [Mark] So bleak, there's so few chances,
when I grew up I could
have been a lawyer, doctor,
politician, I chose photographer,
but I could have done anything.
A lot of these kids I talked to were like,
they didn't have a chance in hell.
They didn't know what a
photographer looked like,
or a doctor or a lawyer, they didn't know,
how would you even do that?
- So, what I see is,
there's no hope for the
black people no more.
- [Mark] That's what I'm
saying, they don't have hope.
- I mean, shit.
- [Mark] That needs to change.
- Shit, it ain't gon' change.
I remember when I was
in junior high school,
I used to come down on May
and it was homeless then,
but I didn't know about it.
I didn't think it,
I seen people hanging out
on the streets, sleeping.
I didn't think nothing about homelessness,
but shit, it was there,
and shit, then I did 18 years
in prison and it's still here.
- [Mark] It's still here.
- It's not gon' change,
- [Mark] What I'm hoping is
by putting out these videos,
maybe creating a little bit of awareness,
about how bad it is and how
how tough it is for some people
and how they got that way.
Like, how does a girl end
up as a heroin addict,
as a crack addict on the street,
selling her body to make a
buck and that's her only,
given up her kids and that's her life,
and she has no hope for anything better,
nothing, no miracle is gonna
come out of the woodwork
and save her life.
- 'Cause she's used to
this, that's all she knows.
- [Mark] A lot of it is a self worth,
that they didn't ever develop,
because their parents
treated them like crap
or abandoned them and
they were in foster homes.
- They guy beating them
up and that kinda shit.
- [Mark] They were
molested at six years old,
they were in foster homes, they had crap.
I had supportive parents, I
had parents that loved me,
they still do.
They were consistent,
so I had that wonderful upbringing
that a lot of the people
I'm talking to, (chuckles)
they wouldn't even know
what that looked like.
They have no idea.
They didn't even know their parents,
the foster home treated them like crap
and they ran away from the
foster home as teenagers
and they grew up in the street.
What does a young girl do
on the street to make money?
'Cause she needs money, right?
There you go.
That's a terrible thing
that goes on in our society
and it goes on a lot,
people just would rather not look at it.
So I'm putting out these
painful, hard to look at videos--
- The people at the top
know what is going on.
- [Mark] I think a lot of people
just would rather not look at
it, pretend it doesn't happen
and by putting out these videos,
just kinda maybe create awareness
and maybe help people...
What I'm hoping, 'cause I don't know
that I'm gonna save a heroin addict,
that's currently an addict.
(T chuckles)
- They can be saved.
- [Mark] I don't think they can be saved.
Maybe there's a couple that
somehow resurrect themselves
and rebuild their lives and
that's beautiful to see,
but those are rare.
But what I'm hoping is by
maybe putting out these videos,
somebody that's about to have kids,
or maybe just had a kid
might decide to like,
"Shit, (chuckles) maybe I
should be there for my kids".
- Each generation is
getting worse and worse.
- [Mark] That's what I'm
saying and what I'm doing,
what I hope is that the next generation,
might actually get it together.
Or maybe we'll help them
get to get it together,
by having more opportunities for them,
more wealth gets shared,
partially it's gonna be less
greed in the government,
less greed in society,
that might somehow help
these communities get their shit together.
- Well, all the black singers
and rappers and all that shit,
they don't, I don't see them doing nothing
to help our own people.
- [Mark] No, it's across the board,
it's not just white people.
- Everybody for theyself.
- [Mark] Yeah, it's sad.
I'm not sure.
Sometimes I think we can make
a difference and sometimes
(chuckles) I get discouraged,
but it's going on, you know?
And it goes on in other cities too,
everybody thinks it's just Skid Row.
It's in Chicago, it's in
Detroit, it's in Philadelphia--
- Oh they got Skid Rows in every city.
- [Mark] Every city I've been
to every state in the country
and I see different versions
of this in North Dakota,
in Florida, in Texas, in
Mississippi, it goes on all over,
take your pick, it just
looks a little different
and it's in different neighborhoods.
Some are worse than others,
this is one of the worst ones.
- It's a lot of homeless out
here because everybody comes
from other States to be
out here for the weather.
- [Mark] Yeah, the weather's great
and the support is here.
You want food?
Look at the nice clothes you get to wear,
you got those from one
of the missions, right?
Or people handing out clothes or food,
or there's even a place to
take a shower down the street.
- I don't even need any mission.
- [Mark] Yeah, you can get it.
- I buy my food.
- [Mark] Yeah, that's what I'm saying,
you found a place, a way to make money,
so you can buy and get what you need.
But, even if you were unwilling
to do shit for yourself,
you can get clothing, you can
get a 10, you can get shit.
- I don't sleep in the
mission, I can't do it.
- [Mark] It's encouraging
that you actually wanna
get your ass outta here,
'cause most people just don't even have,
the wherewithal to do that.
- And plus, I still got my family.
They're trynna find a place,
they help me and stuff.
They know him down here.
- [Mark] Family is a huge
part of this whole thing
and when the family breaks apart,
as it does for 95% of the
people I've talked to,
then everything else falls apart.
- Shoot, if I didn't have no
family, I'd still keep going,
I'd still keep pushing,
I wouldn't break down
and then, I just keep it rolling.
- [Mark] Not everyone gets broken
by these terrible childhoods.
Some people actually
pull their shit together,
they work harder, they focus
and they build their life
kind of on their own,
all by themselves, on their own.
There's all kinds of stories
and there's people that have
done great things with nothing
and there's people who have given up
and just fallen down here,
which is the bottom of the barrel,
even though they had great
support from their families
and there's all kinds of stories.
I'm just creating some awareness,
of all these different
stories, there's a video of it.
- Go talk to the, shit the governor
or the president or somebody.
- [Mark] Maybe somebody, one
day, will see these things
and it'll wake somebody up a little bit.
- 'Cause it seems like they don't care.
- [Mark] If you didn't have to do anything
and you can get to keep your money,
what would you do?
- They help other countries
before they help us.
They do.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- This place is starting to become
like a central American or something.
The whole place is full of Mexicans,
shit that's all I eat, is
Mexican food,(both giggle)
they got it together though,
'cause they look out for each other.
I know that.
- [Mark] Families are a huge part of it,
that's why one of the questions
that I always ask is like,
"Tell me about your family".
'Cause that seems to
be like a huge factor,
in somebody having the
strength to persevere
and get through life.
- Shoot, I had it bad
down here at one time,
shoot and I called my brother I said,
"Man, I'm tired of living on the street.
He said, "I'mma try to find you a place".
It took like shit about a month,
he called me and said, "You ready?",
I said, "Yeah".
He said, "I'mma come get you next week".
He found me a place, but
shit, I fucked it up.
It wasn't my fault
and it was, I liked it.
I was in Rosita,
then I lost that place
and I ended up down here,
I just said, "Fuck it".
Then they found me another place,
then I let some girl come over
and then she fucked the place up.
- [Mark] Is that the one that burned down?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- So I'm back down here and it's hard,
it seems like it's harder
now to find a place,
'cause I was paying 800 there,
now all the places I'm looking at online,
it's like 11, 12, 13, 14.
I don't know how I'mma do it but,
I don't know,
but I'mma get outta here,
I'mma get outta here,
in four more months.
I'mma let you know.
- [Mark] All right T.
- [T] Four more months.
- Good for you.
- I'mma get out of here.
- [Mark] I'd love to see that.
- Huh?
- Oh yeah?
- [Mark] I'd love to talk
to you after you do it too,
- All right
- [Mark] I'll be back.
All right T, thank you for talking to me.
- All right, thank you.
- [Mark] Good luck with everything.